>> Kevin: FOUR SUNS IN DOUBLE
FIGURES.
BRIDGES, CROWDER AND AYTON WITH
11 APIECE.
A LITTLE SHOVE HERE WITH GORDON
AND CROWDER.
THEY HAVE TO BE SEPARATED.
>> Reggie: HERE WE GO.
THEY HAVE BEEN TOO NICE FOR TOO
LONG, AND I WONDERED WHEN
SOMEBODY ON DENVER WAS GOING TO
DO SOMETHING.
BUT MAYBE THEY PICKED THE WRONG
PERSON TO DO SOMETHING AGAINST
IN JAE CROWDER.
I DON'T MIND IT, BUT KNOW YOUR
PERSONNEL.
>> Kevin: WE HAVE EVERY ANGLE
COVERED THERE WITH THE BEST TV
CAMERAMEN IN THE BUSINESS, ANGEL
CORY AND AL BERTIE CHAPMAN AND
RENE COCHRAN AND STEVE ANGEL.
>> Reggie: NOW, ARE THEY
THROWING OUT GORDON?
I THINK IT IS A DOUBLE
TECHNICAL.
>> Kevin: CROWDER PICKED IT UP.
SIDE OUT.
CAMPAZZO ON TOP.
DOUBLE "T"s ON GORDON AND
CROWDER.
AYTON IS OUT ON JOKIC, AND 6 OF
12, AND FINDS CAMPAZZO, AND
SNAPS IT OUTSIDE AND MORRIS WITH
THREE, AND BODIES THROWN OUT OF
BOUNDS, AND A WHISTLE.
>> Reggie: OFFENSIVE FOUL ON
GORDON.
>> Kevin: GORDON IS GOING TO
PICK IT UP.
FRUSTRATED.
HE WAS PICKED UP IN A TRADE WITH
ORLANDO MIDSEASON AND DEFINITE
IMPACT ON THE